and you know that many times a very good
algorithm can reduce the needs of the
hardware what we are for us is very
important
is that
you need to
really do a lot of effort so the
hardware side will be as simple as
possible and as cost effective as
possible
we don't want that the cost of the
hardware will be the the barrier to
implement and we want people to think
about what they need and then use only
what they need but to have it in a very
optimized way so you don't have a lot of
different and fragmented solutions but
you have one holistic platform that
bring everything merge all the data
okay and then give you something that's
taking into account all the data all the
sensors and you invest one time
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serrano partners and in media
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders and meet
eran ben schmuel the ceo and co-founder
of jugano
beginning his career unconventionally is
a classical violinist he changed
direction and earned his bsc in
electrical engineering and physics from
the technion israel institute of
technology iran has over 15 years of
experience building high tech companies
from zero to mass production and he is
an expert in solid-state electronics and
high-speed control systems and he holds
numerous patents in physics and
algorithms
jugan was his second startup with his
partner alex balczynski
the first startup of the two was rf
dynamics the invention was the magical
oven a technology that allows high
degree of control and rapid energy
transfer to food products based on
digital high power rf components capable
of modifying the frequency amplitude and
phase of radio waves transmitted in
ovens he always brings together a wide
range of tech fields to solve unmet
needs just like he did in jugano which
significantly impacts people's lives for
example what they're doing lately in
philadelphia arlington mexico guatemala
and brazil meet iran
iran ben shmuel ceo of jugandu welcome
to 20 minute leaders how are you
very good excited to be here
i'm excited to talk about science about
technology ai but but all of that
towards a greater vision for a greater
future where our cities are connected
our retail is connected we're in the
data-driven world
which allows for pretty much everybody
to be to be connected and to make good
proper decisions and hopefully also
create a bit of lighting along the way
so again thank you so much for for
joining me today i'm really excited
my pleasure
you're a scientist
by background uh
yet also an entrepreneurial and you sort
of you you spend your your career diving
into deep scientific research and then
implementing really interesting of the
interesting insights into these
companies
what sort of guides you in the way that
you think through research or science
that excites you
i always attracted to the science that
can lead to some
you know results that we can see and and
and you can feel then you can
uh you really see the impact that you
are doing yeah
in the short term more or less you know
not the science now that we do the
impact in 20 years this is what captured
me so
i always
were amazed by the ability to um to
imagine something and see it in
realization
and uh i like to imagine i like to uh
uh i like
the fact that i can be creative and work
in this you know so so to to do
something creative and and to impact
and uh i think the technology can
be very meaningful to our life and um
this was uh the the main issue that
attracted me and i think that
i was dealing with such
a variety of technologies that was
every day my life is is very exciting so
i i think that i'm
i'm very fortunate about it
i love that that sentence every day my
life is my everyday my life is very
exciting i think that's a if i had to to
bring together what are you know the the
the way that i want to live my life or
or why we do what we do it's exactly for
that reason
a little bit about jugano tell me even
before what jugam does paint me a
picture of of the world today
and you know we go out to the street and
we see beautiful weather and beautiful
streets yet yet you perceive something
meaningful that is missing for us
what is that i think that the contrast
between the the world that we are living
that is is in the online
such an amazing world
feel that
you're doing shopping online you feel
that they know you
uh you have such a
strong tools in the online while in the
offline usually you don't have it of
course all of us are used to uh to see
uh tools that are mainly connected to
our security
or in the retailer
yes you used to see some things that are
are a
you know very fragmented um and and what
really triggers is and and you see a lot
of development in the ai world all the
capabilities of the machine to help and
and really speaks about things that can
do good impact okay i don't really mess
with the uh or care about things that
are connecting to um
mainly about security or these things
but to do some some some really impact
on us as shoppers as people that live in
a city
and that and the concern between the
huge capability in the ai side in the
connectivity side and and and in the uh
in the other side to see the digital
world so development uh
such a development and in the
in in the bottom line you are going to
um to a supermarket
i and you buy exactly like my
grandmother boat so so there is no big
difference i go inside i look for the
product
and i feel it can be much better you
know to go in the street and see someone
falling and you need someone to call
help you know it's it's not a a
it's really difficult to understand why
in in these times it's like this
so i think that
to bring the technology to do a really
impact to help starting from the lights
by the way
the lighting
why not to create lights that are like
the sunlight okay why to read artificial
light that is so much disinvented
it's something unacceptable and the
communication how you you take the data
that we are leave make it
accessible and put all the tools that
amazing people created a lot of insights
a lot of creative thinking and bring it
to realization and to really insight
that can help us and this was between me
and this was the basic of qigla jogan
wants to take the offline world
uh and to make it accessible to bring
all the digital tools
to be
it to be insights and to be accessible
in the orphan
that's incredible
what type of world does that make so
what what is sort of the
the i mean
it is it does sound intuitive like this
is something we want but but what type
of world
does it allow for us to have what what
what impact does this have down the line
on the way we live our life the way
families raise their children because
you're touching here
on our very livelihood you're touching
on our streets you're touching on our
stores
so how does this unleashing of
creativity that you're talking about how
is that how is that changing sort of the
way that we're gonna live our life
so um i will give you an example in some
place in latin america in some very big
city
there were we installed our system in in
the neighborhoods where people couldn't
go out
uh during the evening
uh
and feel comfortable and enjoy and do
sport and go with the family because of
security because of of uh understanding
they are they don't have the real
support to have if they have some
problem or something and and after we
install the system i went there and it
was amazing to see how people because of
this transformation it's connected to
light communication so digital tools uh
tools um
they start to go in the night to start
to enjoy uh with their families in the
evening and i think that this is one of
the biggest things that i i experienced
that that made big changes to uh to
people how they live but i think it can
be much
more than this when we envision
autonomous cars when we we envision all
the connectivity that
uh uh we start to see
that a lot of technologies start to
combine together you know in order to
give us a lot of um benefits
um so when you go in the streets
and and and and my child that is a small
child i have four children so my my uh a
five
and a half years old child
is doing a mistake and wants to cross
the streets i want to know that there is
some alarm that's along the the the
driver's beaker or oh some danger can
come okay it's look like a dream but
actually now we are doing a system like
this and it's it's it's connected and
and it's it's uh allowing the the the
cars uh but in the same time
not only transferring the the data to
the to the car
but actually change the color of the
lights in order to alarm this is a
dangerous be careful so it's
the light become from white white
to um to red light and and blinky so
very simple thing very visual thing and
just you know even if it save one child
it's not good enough so i think that
this is something that is really crucial
that the infrastructure will help us to
live better
right i think it's a i i i love that
example because then obviously
very easily we all agree save one child
isn't that enough for us to to to to put
this throughout the whole city and
obviously the answer is yes it is enough
and the implications are endless right
because then we're talking about
connectivity it's not a clo necessarily
just a closed system we're talking about
in near future of autonomous cars and
today
we're talking about getting to precision
and accuracy with our existing sensors
that are limited by nature
from their visual fields then by adding
additional layers of parameters from
sensors across the domain i think that
obviously it's it's incredible tell me a
little bit about gigan was a company now
so
so sort of
what did you do what did you develop as
as giugano and sort of the
implementations to date
in geogano we are solving some basic
problems that
uh
cause
a a very big
uh barrier from cities and retail to
implement digital solutions one of them
is the initial cost everyone speaks
about 5g but we all know that in order
to implement 5g real fighter with with
really good bandwidth and good
connectivity um you need to invest a lot
of money
and and in order for this uh we try to
harness the technology
uh to enable sophisticated system to
reduce this initial cost reduces barrier
and only when you are doing it you can
enable
uh
the spread of this
hybrid communication in areas when you
don't have
a lot of money that you can you know in
the middle of manhattan to put some
connectivity but to put it really in
every corner in every place in the u.s
in the world i in in brazil in mexico in
guatemala not about only the rich parts
can put like few blocks
uh in order to do it because everyone
deserve good connectivity i think that
that the president biden say that the
the connectivity is the new uh
electricity
i think that people now expect to have
good connectivity good access and in the
pandemic we saw that if you don't have
ground connectivity you are just left
out from the on the ability to be
connected and
and and i think that
what we did
we created the ability
to connect one point to another point to
another point and this is how you do 100
thousands of points
only by wireless connectivity we created
a very complex but in the end very
simple to install a system that just
deliver the data between one to the
other in a very efficient way very
robust way so it will be
the the the back or the the baseline for
deployment of bing installations and
creating a a a a platform we call it a
platform that can enable implementation
of 5g
access points
small cells uh wi-fi access points
can can you can implement sensors
multiple sensors it can be connected to
the existing sensors and bring a lot of
data to one place and to bring the data
analyze the data locally in the file
edge in the feature
and then you literally create smart city
in the effort of changing the light bulb
so it's the easiest thing to do and now
you create this sophisticated system
that can enable you to have all the
access all the benefits of smart
okay so you so we're saying you know on
one hand it's just it's a it's an easy
thing to do but but it does require
you know i'm conceiving of two
two-way blocks and there are probably
more but one of them perhaps is a
regulatory one where you have to first
explain what you just explained to me
you have to explain it to governments
and to municipalities and i'm curious to
hear what that conversation is like and
i'm also curious to hear about
sort of the operational process of doing
it because you have to essentially
go and perform some infrastructural
operation or not infrastructure we have
to do some operation across
the city in order for it to be connected
and be meaningful how do those thing two
things play out in your world
first of all it's a process uh and when
we speak about cities is to uh to be um
with the right attitude to understand
that uh both parties need to be
need to feel comfortable and good is the
city and it's the citizens they need to
feel good they need to feel that this uh
um
a solution comes to help
and come to bring value to them
so uh we are doing pilots we are doing
installations we are
working with the different companies
different cities worldwide by the way we
are now in a very big implementation in
brazil for five year deployment but in
the same time bring them the value of
the of the uh
safety of the of the uh
heat maps of uh a traffic management of
traffic light control everything that
bring them the holistic solution
uh so sometimes we are working with
government and certainly we work in
municipalities sometimes with the
companies that have the
the the will and the need to do this
transformation it's a lot of companies
that try to uh to do it and i think that
story slowly it's become something that
people feel uh that they need it
because a technology can be threatened
but it can be something that really
change your life and and i think that if
you do it in responsible world and in a
very honest way understand that you own
no data it's not yours it's a
municipality it's the people you are
only here to help to guide to make
things accessible and and you do your
best in order to give them the tools to
manage their data and their uh
infrastructure
and you are only a tool so that's all so
uh you give them the tools and and and
and they are using it for the benefit uh
but you give good tools in order
for them to uh
uh to bring a lot of value and insights
so they can manage better the city
manage better dispose and and and give a
lot of value
so there is the software side and the
hardware side right of this company
and which presents you know it's almost
two different challenges
that one you know you need the hardware
in order to feed to get the data for the
software you need the software to give
the value
to the to the decision makers at the end
what what about this strategy you know
because it's it sounds difficult to be
able to do both and do both very well it
was that a necessary condition for this
company to
to to thrive
were there different considerations
there
in the end if you want exposure to an
ability to take data to analyze you need
to be there you need to do something you
need to install
so this is the hardness side and we work
very hard so it will be easy to
implement and not difficult to replace
the light bulb is not something too
difficult to do it's something that
people do every day in every place in
the world it's not something difficult
it's something uh and when it's modular
and you can put
any any number you want you can start
and and and and grow with this um
in the software side
it has to be a something that is
connected between software and others
because you need to implement the basic
uh um
hardware but you need to do a very
sophisticated software in order to
support it so you get really good data
and you get uh good analysis and you get
the right background you know the an
infrastructure in order to run you know
all the tools that you need ai needs
very good data
um and you need to uh
to make sure that this data is good and
and you can implement tools that bring
real data and accurate
right
so that that
balance
because how do you know how much even as
a ceo
resources to put on on one versus the
other you can continue
building out the hardware to get more
and more data you can
shift some of those resources to
building out the software are there
limitations i mean do you see them as
sort of competing for resources within
the company or is it or is it mainly you
know two verticals which you're growing
as much as possible that you can grow
them and they're they don't necessarily
compete against each other well i i see
them very complimentary because
understand we are doing the platform we
are right
and our goal all the time was through a
platform that can be used by third party
as well as uganda so we are not trying
to say if you implement this uh platform
we need to use gugam applications no try
to make this data accessible and then
amazing people come with a great ideas
use the data
and then give amazing insights
so our goal is to make this uh our
platform uh optimized regarding the
hardware and the software in order to
give
the tools to developer to sell parties
to bring the tools and and and to um the
insights uh and bring all the value to
the customers and to the cities the
written so uh basically it's it's it's
growing together and you know that many
times a very good
algorithm can reduce the needs of the
hardware what we are for us is very
important
is that
you need to
really do a lot of effort so the
hardware side will be as simple as
possible and as cost effective as
possible
we don't want that the cost of the
hardware will be the the barrier to
liquid and we want people to think about
what they need and then use only what
they need but to have it in a very
optimized way so you don't have a lot of
different and fragmented solution but
you have one holistic platform that
bring everything merge all the data
okay and then give you something that's
taking into account all the data all the
sensors and you invest one time i
believe that as we are a company that
even developed a technology for lighting
it's part of our system
yep you need to think about the
environment and about the environment
it's to save a lot the maximum that you
can but to save with infrastructure it's
not possible that people put every
other thing that they need they create
another infrastructure
it's just not possible you need to be
optimized with these two and then the
effort to do it will be optimized and
minimum
iran it's a it's fascinating on so many
degrees because i think that what one of
the things that that you know it's
amazing for me is that you're working on
something that that
once it'll once we'll have that it'll
seem so trivial and it'll seem so
obvious that we that humanity needed it
yet today it seems like it's it's a
still
not science fiction but it seems a
little bit futuristic and and it's not a
central conversation but but you know
companies like jugando i mean that's
exactly where where my inspiration stems
from and i can only imagine
all the creative use cases of what
people can do and what software can do
with the data that you will be creating
uh i think that it's a it's remarkable
and i am still with that thought of that
image of a car coming into the driveway
within you know a neighborhood and all
of a sudden the street lights changing
or perhaps an alarm sounding and and
lives being saved because we have this
ability for connectedness and to
integrate this data so i think it's
amazing and i appreciate your time and
your energy and uh i wish you best of
luck with giugano and i can't wait to
see what happens
thank you i will invite you to see
interesting implementation with center i
think it's uh thank you for your kind
words and uh happy to talk on everyone
i'm i'm ready thank you alan thank you